ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
fällt meine lieben
warum geht's überhaupt da oben
heute ist es soweit wir werden die halle
betreten in minecraft ich bin richtig
gespannt ich glaube ich war bisher vor
keiner minecraft folge so dass hierfür
eine party ich war vor keiner mannschaft
folge bisher so geisteskranken nervös
und werde deswegen jetzt auch erstmal
handeln ich brauche nämlich dass
feuerschutz neues buch das blut in die
kommentare geschrieben denn an alle die
den mieter nicht kennen das ist die
hölle im ring kraft und da ist nahezu
nur lava nur rote blöcke kein
quadratmeter grün oder wasser oder
irgendwas deswegen ist das feuerschutz
buch extrem wichtig ich würde sagen wir
kaufen uns auch noch glück 3a krass dass
ihre dass er das auch tat im angebot hat
das hier glück drei das können sie
nämlich auf deine spitzhacke packen und
wenn wir mit der spitzhacke dann
irgendwie beispielsweise diamanten
finden sollten und diese abbauen wird
sein dass wir nicht nur einen bekommen
sondern auch bei 5 oder 30er ok 30
bisschen unwahrscheinlich was brauchen
die kommentare geschrieben wurde war
luca du brauchst im netto auf jeden fall
ein gold rüstungsteile damit die pick
links damit die mich als verbündeten
anerkennen und ich werde mir auch noch
einen neuen eisen harnisch machen und
diesen auch direkt verzaubern mit dem
feuerschutz kostet eine erfahrung und
dann tausche ich den der kaputt war aus
gegen den hier und jetzt haben wir
einmal gold nur hose und gucci das ding
mit bescheid wird bevor wir allerdings
in die hölle gehen muss sich diese eier
hier noch ein bisschen weitläufiger
einwohner mit dem bisschen mehr platz
haben das wird nämlich auch in die
kommentare geschrieben ehe luca du hast
den eiern viel zu wenig platz gegeben
jetzt sehr logisch dass sie da nicht
stiften können und hier hat das altern
auch ein bisschen mehr platz also das
haben wir auf jeden fall auch gemacht
danke euch da auf jeden fall für die
ganzen tipps und in den kommentaren und
jetzt
der moment der wahrheit freunde wir
hüpfen zu unserer portal in
es ist ein kleiner schritt für die
menschheit aber ein großer schritt
also eigentlich auch nur ein kleiner
schritt für mich aber ich gehöre
eben nicht wieder frei
[Musik]
aber ist dass sie grün
[Applaus]
dessen diese zombie pacman ist er grün
ich darf mich allerdings nicht ablenken
lassen meine lieben freunde ich brauche
erstmal diese komischen sachen ja ist
das erde das ist für viele war wir
warten blog die blöcke tools anscheinend
nichts von daher können wir die
theoretisch stehen lassen und baut jetzt
erst mal um unser portal rum eine kleine
durchsagen ich fühle mich ist es ein
erfolg dass ich noch nicht tot bin
es ist schon ein bisschen beängstigend
finde ich ich baue hier gerade ein
portal ein
in der hellen welt und hier unten sind
riesige mengen an lava
schaut euch das an
unser gefallen die sind irgendwie
aufgebracht
ganz vorsichtig ganz vorsichtig nicht
sogar stürzen
also mir wird ja in die kommentare
explosionsschutz
prozesstag
dass wir auch die punkte ab ich habe
keinen plan wer das ist und ob er mich
mag oder nicht aber es läuft gerade zu
den anderen leuten die option ihre ich
werde ihn jetzt einfach wenn ich ihn
schlagen
ich weiß es nicht wir chancen ich habe
volles leben und rüstung
der sieht so aus als ob er an gott
schaden gemacht und der zweck gelaufen
und jetzt kommt er dagegen eine wand
kate die tun mir nichts weil ich das
gold rüstungsteilen habe mir wurde
geschrieben wenn ich goldbarren nehme
und jetzt kann ich ihm wollen goldbarren
hinschmeißen
ich habe ein bisschen schiss vor den
ehrlich gesagt ich schmeiße ihm einen
goldbarren himmel
jetzt hat er hat ihn erding was machst
du damit jetzt sexy in sand die kriege
auf ebay für 30 cent ich habe keine
ahnung was bei diesem pekings abgeht ich
versuche jetzt nochmal mit dem gold das
sie jetzt glaube ich ein anderer mit dem
habe ich noch nicht getradet er doch von
ganz komischen bogen irgendwie in der
hand es gibt er mir jetzt er gibt mir
schwarz stein wo ich dachte führen gold
kriegt man vielleicht mal diamant oder
so ich weiß nicht ob das dann diese
tickets sind aber scheint der fall zu
sein
um trotzdem jetzt erstmal die ganzen
sachen heraus ich hab da oben ist ein
gold blog da gehe ich auf jeden fall mal
kurz hin
das kann ja auch nicht verkehrt sein
wird zunehmen was das hier ist keine
ahnung ich trau mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so richtig
ich habe gerade mit euch handelt ich
habe gerade recht
jetzt ist ich sag's euch jetzt ist krieg
angesagt jetzt einfach krieg angesagt
schiff insel schütt heile welt ich
befinde mich im krieg mit dem verdammten
beschreibt das kenne ich nicht
euro
denn jetzt schon wieder wollen ich weiß
nicht ob die mich jetzt attackieren oder
nicht der kleine nicht komm ich gebe dem
kleinen mann stück gold
ich weiß ich habe dann auch mit traded
hier erholt sich was gibst du mir
kleiner man diese ganze ecke ist mir auf
jeden fall ein bisschen nicht so ganz
geheuer dass sie zwar sehr interessant
aus da hinten da wird auch ordentlich
weitergehen aber ich entscheide mich
doch mal für die andere richtung das
portal ist eingebaut da kann eigentlich
nichts mit passieren wenn irgendwer
gegen schießt oder irgendwelche gas oder
so also geister so weiter und so fort
hier ist der ändern
ich weiß nicht wann es im netz solche
komischen bionik gibt von wegen
das ist jetzt das vier billionen und
hier ist alles irgendwie verwirrend und
keine ahnung was ich mal dass wir sind
ja diese wir pilze respondern scheint
eine menge ändern
das ist ganz gut wenn wir später ans
ende wollen und ein paar der sieht aus
wie sandra ich bei uns hier meinen weg
über die lagerstelle dann kann er da
zwar nicht mehr durch ich weiß nicht ob
er mich attackiert aber er sieht recht
verbunden aus mit uns auf jeden fall
gern bitte weiterhin in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr ideen habt
irgendwelche tipps trifft tricks tipps
und so weiter und so fort
ich kann gar nicht richtig reden ich bin
wirklich wirklich extrem angespannt und
das war ich so bisher von keiner anderen
minecraft folge davor dass irgendein
eingang zu tun wird sagt sich das ist
die attacke mich nicht sagt sich das ist
eine festung zieht die nicht voll selten
also ich hab zwar schon lange kein
minecraft mehr gespielt aber das hier
weiß ich noch dass die ich will keinem
erzählen wie viel verdammtes glückliche
diesem projekt habe hier ist einfach der
eingang zu einer riesigen festung falls
nicht was das ist da findet man zum
beispiel ohren und so weiter und so fort
und hier kommt es mal an wie groß das
einfach ist das ist unnormal riesig um
ein portal steht dahin ich weiß nicht ob
man es noch sieht wenn ich immer ein
bisschen höher gehe aber davon ist auf
jeden fall mein portal also ich bin
nicht mehr als 100 150 blöcke geladen
ich würde sagen wir begeben uns einfach
mal in die festung hier rein
ich weiß nicht ob das eine gute idee ist
da hinten sind eine menge ändern wenn
hier so eine menge zombie plänen die
sind allerdings neutral uns gegenüber
von daher würde ich sagen gehen wir
jetzt einfach mal rein wir wollten tipp
und in die kommentare geschrieben das
sich nur rechts die fackeln packen soll
bezüglich ausleuchten dass das wohl ganz
gut sein würde weil ich dann den ausgang
leichter finde da hinten sehe ich eine
kiste
ihr müsst euch vorstellen in diesen
ruinen hier
tonnen mit die stärksten monster im
ganzen spiel wir haben sattel
becker wir können uns einfach ein pferd
hohl und wieder direkt gefährde rüstung
in diesen festungen spawnen die
stärksten monster dies in minecraft gibt
und zwar weder skelette
ihr seht schon wie die aussehen
ich werde jetzt einfach mal die wurzeln
hier drin lassen damit ich zumindest die
rüstung noch mitnehmen kann gold wert
brauche ich jetzt nicht hdk kuba dar
einfallen wie recht nicht so schnell ich
ganz vorsichtig nach vorne ist nichts
ich bin richtig nervös möchte die
heutige folge auf jeden fall in unserer
welt beenden und nicht im dach das
skelett mein gott das ist lorenz
potthoff das ist lorenz parade lorenz
bonner ist so unnormal wichtig für uns
weil wir damit einfach ich bin richtig
angespannt
[Musik]
hier atmet irgendwas sehr schwer
ich weiß nicht ob das der londoner ist
[Musik]
ich habe richtig dass gerade ich hab
grad richtig schiss von hier sind wir
gekommen
weder und besondere kiste da waren wir
noch nicht von hier sind wir gesprochen
es sind immer lauter es wird immer
lauter
ich habe schiss vor jeder jeder scheiß
kurve in diesen dingen hier ist doch nur
noch eine kiste
hier ist ende okay wir haben eisen das
kann ich nicht mit dem den goldenen
organisch ich pack mal den carmesin pelz
er ein ich glaube ich auch nicht
unbedingt
dass hier auch mitnehmen habe ich
irgendwo gelesen in den kommentaren
das dass diese
bin jetzt hier proben das in barcelona
das sein okay okay erstmal noch nicht
einfach vergessen
christian klar kommen und damit den
kampf kabinen kamen für einen sagen okay
dass das war jetzt gar nicht mal so
anstrengt
[Musik]
die oh mein gott hast du wohl das geld
ist weg
red
und warum habe ich hier gerade
angefangen zu brennen
obwohl ich auch mein gott ich wollte das
quartett ab
ein
[Musik]
ich bin ich hab so schätz ich weiß nicht
ob das jetzt so funktioniert wie ich mir
das vorstelle aber ich glaube ich habe
das spiel durch sport ich will und ich
ein knochen ich las die vier bretter
jetzt einfach mal hier und den wir
warten blog auch weil das er direkt an
unserem portal auch verfügbar war
die scheiße ist ich habe nur noch eine
fackel ich setze jetzt mal hierhin und
jetzt müssen wir im dunkeln weiter fort
gehen
ich hab schiss vor allem mit diesen
geräuschen die sich anwenden
[Musik]
ich finde das hier allerdings
mittlerweile schon so heftig dass ich
mein portal aufsuchen werde und auf
jeden fall erstmal einige sachen helfen
werde so dass sich die nicht verliere
ich habe schon eine lohn route ich habe
die netto wurzeln allerdings haben wir
hier vorne ja schon mal relativ zügig
jetzt den ausgang gefunden und es sieht
so heftig aus die sander da es ist so
geisteskrank heftig ich dachte wirklich
übertreibt in den kommentaren als emmett
hey ich will sehen wie luca im netter
abgeht ich will sehen wie seine reaktion
ist auf die ganzen sachen die ihnen
zugefügt worden und ich dachte
übertreibt aber die haben ja den netto
fast schon krasser gemacht als die
eigene warum attacke nämlich der hat
mich angegriffen ich habe zwei gold-
sachen an und ich habe gold dabei also
ich weiß nicht warum die teile mich
angreifen
aber dafür ist er die kommentare sektion
da freunde und dann würde ich mich
wirklich sehr sehr freuen wenn ihr in
den kommentaren ein bisschen
weiterhelfen würde ich nehme noch mal
hier oben den kloß ton mit ist das
kloster
hits licht also ich bin hier wirklich
völlig verloren
ich bin ja eh schon in der normalen
minecraft welten bisschen verloren weil
als ich damals minecraft gespielt habe
und das war wirklich vor diesem projekt
das letzte mal so richtig vorjahren
da gab es ganz ganz viele sachen noch
nicht sondern da hat man halt das alles
noch gemacht und da war mannschaft noch
nicht so geisteskrank komplex wie es
jetzt gerade aktuell der fall ist ich
bin wirklich auf eure tipps angewiesen
ich bin wirklich auf eure tipps
angewiesen ich freue mich einfach nur
dass ich mir hier vorne gemerkt habe wo
das portal steht da wurde nämlich auch
in die kommentare geschrieben
luca du musst dir auf jeden fall die
koordinaten von dem portal
wir hatten das doch hier oder da oben
ist es mir wurde geschrieben hat du
musst ja auf jeden fall die koordinaten
von dem portal merken das ist in meinen
augen aber und zu dumm dass auch
wirklich klingen mag ist dass schiiten
ich finde wenn ich jetzt f3 druck und
die koordinaten sehe das könnte ja nicht
in real life machen
von daher ist das für mich das kommt bei
mir nicht in die tüte
und jetzt meine lieben freunde begeben
wir uns wieder zurück in meine richtige
welt
ich bin so froh wieder hier zu sein wo
wir jetzt gerade angekommen sind können
wir auch mal kurz unsere
schildkröteneier begutachten das hier
unten als jetzt auch so ein bisschen
gerissen da wurde noch geschrieben luca
die nicht kaputt die schlüpfen einfach
so langsam das heißt es funktioniert auf
jeden fall dass hier und das hier noch
nicht allerdings braucht wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen sind halt schildkröten die
brauchen für alles ein bisschen was das
hier schön die sonne geht unter
ihr könnt uns auch noch mal kurz zum
kleinen witz erzählen lassen von unserem
witz baum hier einziger witz hier bist
du ja meine lieben freunde an der stelle
würde ich allerdings sagen die sonne
geht unter wir begeben uns oben in unser
häuschen rein das schweinchen wartet auf
uns ich kann die ganzen geilen sachen
sicher nie wieder wie am platz mehr drin
ich nehme einfach dass wir drüber für
das nett akkurat für die eisenbahn für
alles was wir aus dem lager geholt hatte
ich einfach mal hier rein
ich bin echt happy wie die folge heute
gelaufen ist also nicht in dem sinne wie
sie bei euch an kam das weiß natürlich
auch nicht kann ja sein dass er sagt ich
hätte mir das viel mehr erwartet bei der
episode
allerdings war es für mich wirklich
geisteskrank zu sehen wie sich das
entwickelt hat in den letzten jahren und
wie viel ich anscheinend auf täglich
verpasst habe ich habe tatsächlich eine
armbrust mitgenommen aber dies fast
schon kaputt ich kann allerdings bei
versuchen
und sie ist kaputt an der stelle würde
ich die heutige episode minecraft mit
luca jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
das kann einen daumen hoch unter dem
video er da schreibt mir wie bereits
gesagt ganz ganz viele tipps für den
neckar und in die kommentare und
abonniert main kanal falls die neue
nächste episode minecraft mit luca nicht
verpassen wollte die kommt nämlich
übermorgen am dienstag um 20 uhr online
und ihr können wir auch noch in die
kommentare schreiben was ich dort machen
soll
soll ich noch mal in den äther gehen mit
ein bisschen mehr vorbereitung noch mal
die
festungen mir anschauen oder soll ich
mal was an der insel wieder verändern
schreibt schon in die kommentare wir
sehen uns übermorgen che
[Musik]